[Musique]
allons sur la terre je suis bien content
de voir répond le cheval un petit
instant nounours les enfants
tu as l'air bien pressé ce soir oui
patron j'ai des deux une terrible à
poser à pimprenelle et à nicolas et je
suis sûr qu'ils ne le trouveront pas
propre aux pommes pour poupons ils se
croient bien malin notre gros nounours
tiens tu attendais ne vaut soir mes
petits
vous aimez les devinettes oui alors il
coûtait bien il est petit il a de grands
yeux il boit du lait il marche à quatre
pattes lui quelques ripoux style
au menu du pour le choisir plus facile
que de vue notre pierrot
ah non il n'est jamais rose elle n'aime
pas aller dans l'eau très bien le petit
elles sont bonnes mais de démarches
aussi à 4 pas celui là
annie pas trop difficile est facile il a
de grosses vos rêves il remue la queue
et il s'appelle mais dans we hill feu
vous vous dont il nous l'a mois le chien
aboie goûts et les chats et les ans au
quai style tiens oui mais ensuite ils
vont au tour à l'eau on a beau
[Musique]
hugo tout petit nom ni encore après on
dormira comme des anges dont l'un des
revenus le groupe hole aux pompes
elles mangent de l'herbe dans le champ
et elle donne du boulot de laquelle
bruit c'est un troupeau entier qui vient
dans celui je me sauve moi j'ai peur
demain les [ __ ] ni nicolas sonina
prenait corps bien
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants embrasser bien fort
votre papa et votre maman est allée
sagement vous coucher comme nicolas et
pimprenelle ce qu'ils sont gentils
patrons il d'orb du genre en route
fidèle compagnon bonne nuit à demain à
gogo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]